[Aplausos]
hola buenas tardes
como se le están pasando
qué bueno no les gustan estas botellas
tienen botellas de estas
levanten la mano por favor quién tiene
una botella de plástico en este momento
o durante el transcurso del día ha
utilizado una
ahora bien
levante la mano quien de ustedes sabe a
dónde van a parar estas botellas de
plástico una vez que las tiramos a un
bote de basura
bueno quizá muchos de ustedes se
imaginaron esto botellas tiradas en la
calle en un basurero o también porque no
viviendo en el fondo del mar con bob
sponja no creo que haya sido la única
que lo haya pensado verdad
según cifras de lámpara que cada año se
desechan
450 mil toneladas de botellas de
plástico en méxico esto es como si
llegáramos 127 veces el estadio azteca
cada año
qué pensarían si les dijera que hay un
grupo de jóvenes mexicanos que están
decidiendo o que han decidido
transformar
este escenario
en esto
si en lentes
estos lentes están hechos con 99% de pet
reciclado y la historia la escuché por
primera vez en la ciudad de puebla en un
evento de mentes brillantes en el 2016
ahí fue donde conocí a roberto este
joven mexicano que decidió cambiar la
visión del mundo y llevar a la población
más vulnerable lentes resistentes de
bajo costo y hechos con pet reciclado
pero la historia no acabó ahí durante el
transcurso de dos días me tocó
entrevistar a 29 emprendedores más todos
ellos con historias tan increíbles como
las de roberto y con algo en común todas
surgidas en la adversidad y cobijadas
bajo un mismo nombre emprendimiento
social y permítanme explicarles qué es
el emprendimiento social no sé si alguno
de ustedes ha escuchado que es el
emprendimiento social levanten la mano
bueno pues para los que no lo sepan el
rol del emprendedor social es
cambiar y resolver una problemática de
la sociedad y al mismo tiempo tener un
impacto positivo en temas de transporte
educación alimentación salud vivienda
por mencionar algunos en resumen el
emprendedor social ve oportunidades en
donde los demás ven un problema
para muchos de nosotros quizá el destino
final pues de esta botella sería
el bote de basura en el mejor de los
casos para el emprendedor social no el
emprendedor social cree armazones hace
empaques hace tenis e inclusive
construye casas el es marco antonio es
muy buen amigo que conocí en un evento
de emprendimiento social y utilice el
pet para hacer ladrillos y construir
casas para personas de bajos recursos
como ven por los emprendedores están
todo el tiempo sacando de este de estos
momentos difíciles o de estos momentos
de adversidad cosas nuevas
pues me fue muy inspirada de este evento
en puebla regresé a la ciudad de mexico
y decidí también emprender yo y bueno
pues en que emprendí les voy a contar un
poquito
cuando estaba en puebla preparando toda
esta información todas estas entrevistas
para los emprendedores que en aquel
momento yo no sabía que existían los
emprendedores sociales justamente porque
no había tanta información me di cuenta
que ninguno de estos proyectos estaba
teniendo la difusión adecuada así y
estamos hablando de proyectos que están
cambiando el mundo y no nos estamos
enterando entonces decidí crear un
proyecto junto a mi socio y desde
entonces me volví embajadora permanente
del emprendimiento social en méxico en
américa latina y también decidí ser
embajadora permanente del emprendimiento
social en el mundo y desde entonces me
dedico a contar las historias de todos y
cada uno de ellos en diferentes medios y
pues hoy estoy aquí en ted haciéndolo
estos son los seis pasos que yo me
encontré en este camino del
emprendimiento social
número 1 identifica la problemática así
como roberto como marco como lo hice yo
identifiquen traten de ver en esos
lugares en donde hay adversidad número 2
utiliza tus habilidades para que son
buenos que les apasiona utilicen todo
eso para hacer el bien para ayudar a
otros número 3
profesionaliza te arma un plan de
negocios tengan en cuenta que si quieren
ayudar a más personas
necesitarán recursos entonces su
proyecto tiene que ser rentable si no
saben de ventas de finanzas de marketing
tomen un curso o todos los que sean
necesarios porque lo van a necesitar
número 4 hagan equipo siempre con
personas que sepan más que ustedes
trabajen con la comunidad a la que van a
ayudar a ellos siempre les van a dar un
ello siempre le van a dar un valor
agregado a su producto hagan alianzas
con la iniciativa privada con
industriales con las asociaciones
civiles con el gobierno con otros
emprendedores el emprendedor social es
por naturaleza un enlace entre todos
estos actores
número 5 piensa local sí con g como los
hombres g como el punto g
si quieren que su proyecto trascienda
fronteras y se replique en otras partes
del mundo tienen que pensar globalmente
y actuar localmente
número 6 y última pero ahí no se ve no
importa yo se las digo salgan de su zona
de confort aprendan le a dar un giro a
la manera en la que ven las cosas
yo los invito a que sigamos aprendiendo
a emprender
este es un caso más de emprendimiento
social él es muhammad yunus es icono en
el emprendimiento social y es ganador de
un premio nobel de la paz por haber
fundado de grameen bank este banco es de
microfinanciamientos y él fue el
iniciador o él
si el iniciador de todo este movimiento
otro ejemplo más es paul trainer roberto
alvarado ya lo mencioné marco antonio
jiménez
todos ellos emprendedores sociales y le
han dado un nuevo uso al pp están
también reduciendo el impacto ecológico
otro ejemplo más es el de darío jiménez
gerardo ibarra ana isabel
carlos david santillana ellos han
decidido acercarse a las comunidades
indígenas a las comunidades locales y lo
que están haciendo es reactivando el
campo junto con estas comunidades y
sacando de ahí nuevos productos y los
están llevando a otras partes del mundo
muy interesante por último pero no me
acabo de acabaría en esta charla de
hablar de todos los emprendedores
sociales que he tenido el gusto de
conocer esta daniel martínez jim o tu
bar o chino hace prótesis las imprime en
bueno para la redundancia en impresoras
3d y él le ha cambiado a la vida de
millones de niños él es nuestro claro
que en el emprendimiento social
así que si la próxima vez ustedes
piensan que la vida los tiene en una
situación difícil o que está nadando
contracorriente
piénselo dos veces lo más probable es
que frente a ustedes tengan la
oportunidad para salir de su zona de
confort para transformar sus muros y
para emprender y no sé en una de esas la
oportunidad para cambiar al mundo
recuerden que si ustedes quieren cambiar
al mundo sólo tienen que cambiar la
manera en la que lo ven muchas gracias
[Aplausos]